okay as I told you earlier Donald Trump
is bringing in the the just the normal
horrible depraved lobbyist that he
criticized during his campaign and said
that he would not bring in here's the
stunner though Sarah Palin is being
considered to be part of Donald Trump's
cabinet this is the same Sarah Palin
it's hard to even get through the story
because it's so insane the same Sarah
Palin that is at least partially
responsible for bringing down John
McCain's bid for the presidency might be
in Donald Trump's cabinet a person who
spoke to the Trump campaign told
POLITICO that aides are considering
Sarah Palin for interior secretary Trump
has said he would consider a cabinet
position for Sarah Palin Palin has not
made it a secret that she is interested
in that Sarah Palin Pat I mean the this
is the you can't parody this on Saturday
Night Live because it's the real world
and Sarah Palin has become another
reality of reality TV show star yeah
just like Trump was so it's really
fitting and even Omarosa Manigault from
The Apprentice oh yeah you gotta bring
in Omarosa because she's really going to
be able to uh I mean who knows what it
is she's going to do Donald Trump's son
Don Jr is said to be also interested in
the job of interior secretary Trump's
son I would love a competition of some
kind between Sarah Palin and and Don Jr
maybe the challenge would be they have
to get ingredients with food stamps and
make the best meal for Wolfgang Puck or
something like that I mean make it all a
reality show right well I thought Donald
Jr was gonna be in charge of running
Trump's businesses so you have to see
how that blind trust in the Trump
organization is working out yes a very
very good question a Secretary of State
possibilities Newt Gingrich is a
possibility yeah that's disturbing also
our favorite former US ambassador to the
United Nations who didn't even think the
United Nations should exist John Bolton
a possibility for Secretary of State
this is a clown car ladies and gentlemen
Attorney General I can't believe that
we're having this conversation
but people close to Trump say that
former New York City Mayor Rudolph
Giuliani one of trumps
strongest Public Defenders is the
leading candidate to be the attorney
Attorney General of the United States I
don't know what to say Pat maybe then
he'll be privy to government secrets and
actually know FBI agents who are
currently in the government agency even
worse Commerce Secretary
Trump is said to be considering former
Texas Governor Rick Perry who once
officially conducted a rain dance to try
to ease the drought in Texas maybe the
Commerce Secretary
also Arkansas governor Mike Huckabee
being considered as Commerce Secretary
Health and Human Services Secretary some
of the names receiving buzz I know
you're going to think I'm kidding but
this is all real Florida Governor Rick
Scott new Engrish also being considered
there and ben Carson
possibly the Secretary of Health and
Human Services and this is where it
really gets ugly Pat Homeland Security
Secretary I'm having trouble even
talking about this because it is so
disgusting remember that crazy
conservative sheriff from Milwaukee
County Wisconsin David Clark who's
completely off his rocker I mean we're
talking about one of the most unhinged
law enforcement individuals I've maybe
ever seen in the United States of
America reportedly being considered as
homeland security secretary yeah I I
just don't know what to say
do you see what is going on here ladies
and gentlemen this is a joke this will
be a circus clown car cabinet
this makes george w bush's cabinets look
like the brain trust of political
history by which all others should be
judged this is part of the anti
intellectual movement that I've been
telling you about to save the country
we've got our work cut out for ourselves
that's for sure
let's take a break